what's up fellow Geeks we have a huge
haul from our good friends of creative
and damn is it a lot of stuff today we
have the move ago the pedal Pro sense
small air and my favorite gaming
Soundbar the katana V2 X it's more or
less the same Soundbar but with a
smaller subwoofer but we'll get into
that later on I've had some time with
all these products and they've proven
that they can do the job at an
affordable price with some having a few
caveats my favorite of the lot are the
sensible earphones I've been using them
to edit this video listen to music and
even play a model of a 2 at my desk over
the last few weeks and it's been
enjoyable so far sound quality is a
notch above decent with a little
emphasis on the mids and highs so
whether you're listening to rap metal or
break call it's an enjoyable experience
right out the box with their six
millimeter bio cellulose drivers the
main units are very light and the rubber
tips that come with them are comfortable
I had them on for about two to three
hours before I had to remove them they
are by far the lightest earphones I've
used at 5.2 grams per butt and the case
is just as light at 38 grams the case is
twice as large as the airpods pro gen 1
case so it's not the most subtle but the
buds are stealthy and they fit snugly so
you see it doesn't really fall off even
though I shake my head like that it's
it's a tight fit also it's ipx5
waterproof combined with how stuck they
fit these are great companions for
working out and you won't need to worry
about them coming in contact with water
so the main job to these parts are its
sensible mode in addition to ANC and
ambient mode this is ambient mode but
amped up it actually makes the
environment around you sound much
clearer so hear me out the best way I
can describe sensible mode is you're
playing music on your speakers but
you're still able to hear someone
clearly when they speak to you and if
you don't want to listen to them you can
switch back to ENC on the Fly this is
quite the Plus for runners who want to
be extra careful or anyone that wants to
hear people a lot more clearly say over
the counter also at this price point you
can shape up the EQ how you like which a
lot of other earbuds in this range don't
let you for some reason like seriously
other brands should like consumers have
more control over their song regardless
would I get them for someone who's
looking for an upgrade or just a
dedicated pair of earphones for runners
and gym goers definitely only things are
that they tend to be smudge magnets on
the main butts and the case is kind of
smooth so it will be slippery so just
ignore that now there are a ton of
portable Bluetooth speakers out in the
market with Brands like JBL dominating
the sector how does the movable goal
shape up it's designed for The Great
Outdoors so whether you're exploring the
jungle on a hike going for a long-haul
bike ride or just having a picnic with
your friends the movable goal is
designed for all bumps and weather
conditions being quite rugged despite
its Sleek design an ipx7 waterproof
everything sweet is a deal because I can
literally do this
and it will still function so even if
you hit bad weather the movable goal
will keep going while you work towards
getting to where you need to be all the
way till the end with 18 hours of
battery life on a single charge if
you're in for a good time bumping Tunes
with its 20 watt dual full range micro
drivers with passive radiators and if
you have no idea what that means the
sound is really sick and it gets loud
you can pay two mobile goals and get a
set of stereo speakers however you only
hear a prompt telling you which speaker
is left and right with no indication
afterwards so color-coded LED lights
will be nice to have so this is great
especially for delivery Riders who love
bumping their tunes on their commute to
the destinations and it's lightweight at
570 grams and has a slender build so it
can pretty much fit most bicycle holders
and if you can't fit it in there's still
this Landing up for you to strap onto
something that's what she said
I haven't found any phones with this
piece yet but if you have any questions
about it leave them in the comment
section down below also if you like what
you're hearing so far leave a like and
hit that subscribe button we have a lot
of content coming for all of you so
don't miss out and with the pebble Pros
if you're looking for a pair of speakers
for your computers speak your computers
here's a message from our sponsor this
video is by
MSI meet
Jen into core i7 processor RTX 30 series
graphics and a 16 inch Quad HD Plus
touchscreen panel with a 360 degree
hinge it lets you unleash maximum
productivity with up to 11 hours of
battery life at just 2 kilograms the
summit e16 flip offers unprecedented
performance and functionality allowing
you to work and play anywhere anytime
the pebble Pros are a set of sleek
looking minimalist speakers that come
packing do not be full bite size because
these babies even at medium volume are
pretty loud and pretty to look at it
comes in a nice dark green which is
beautifully accentuated with the RGB at
the bottom of each speaker that you can
sort of customize by using the volume
knob to set the mood for the day and
lighting effects come in three flavors
psycho pulsate and solo there's no
subwoofer that comes with these speakers
instead they have the subwoofer-esque
bits at the back they're calling base
Flex technology that goes hand in hand
with their re-engineered 2.25 inch full
range drivers the speakers really just
do the job and it kind of just sit there
looking pretty you're really paying for
what you get but it is still top of its
class in its price range and a lot more
aesthetically pleasing than a lot of
other speakers I've seen out there also
there are two separate Jacks at the side
for headphones and microphones so just
take note that if you want to use them
on your mic'd up headphones you're gonna
need a splitter also the USB powered so
no worries if you don't have an extra
spot on your power outlet one thing I
wish they gave us the option of was
being able to remove the cables at the
back of the speakers for cable
management and all that they're built in
so keep that in mind so this would be
great for people who want their speakers
take up lesser real estate on the desk
instead of using say a soundbar or any
other larger speakers or monitors out
there and also if you don't need
bombastic sound like the katana these
will do the job so now we'll get into my
favorite song about the katana V2 or in
this case the katana v2x essentially
what creative did with the b2x was gift
the main Samba a nice little paint job
it's more matte ish silver on the top
compared to the brush metal or the of E2
but the major change is in the subwoofer
this is the V2 subwoofer and this is the
V2 XS subwoofer not only is the V2 axis
subwoofer Slimmer and taller than the
thick boy the V2 has here but it's also
less powerful than the V2s and you're
probably asking like isn't that bad you
know it's less powerful and everything
you know ah just having a less powerful
sub is a good thing for smaller spaces
so listening to music or gaming audio
won't have you getting more noise
complaints that I usually get Listen to
I really want to stay at your house for
the millionth time and also then you see
the space by that much like it's quite
substantial look at how much this thing
is and look at how much this thing is
you see belong space so basically power
output wise the v2x puts out 90 RMS with
180 Watts at its peak and the V2 up to
126 RMS with 252 Watts at its peak so in
all honesty there is a change yes but it
isn't significant enough for me to say
that the v2x completely pales in
comparison so whether I'm using the V2
at home or the v2x in the office my
average volume is at 12 and that's what
I can think and what my neighbors can
take but they both can go up to 50. so
that's insanely loud you still get the
same features specs besides the sub and
it's like what 60 bucks off the V2 so I
would definitely get the v2x over the V2
because saving that 60 bucks and I don't
know buying duct tight and hearing my
chainsaw rip and tear through Heretics
with some pumping audio and saving floor
space would definitely be up on my list
if you're looking for a beautiful way to
upgrade your underwater speaker or just
auto experience in general look no
further so if any questions on any of
these products leave them in the comment
section down below and I'll do my best
to get to them drop a like and hit that
subscribe button it goes a long way and
if you want to see more vids like this
check this out
foreign